[Music]
from the first episode
look at that
am i the first episode yeah you own the
first one
come here okay we're premiering taylor
rooks taylor rooks with me duncho
episode one
the biggest the biggest show ever
[Music]
i was talking to my producers about you
coming in and i'm like you know what i
guarantee he's gonna have on at least
two chains
and they're gonna hit the mic
and you have on how many today i got
them
about six but they cool it's the light
it's the light kit today what's the
heavy kit oh the big three migo chain i
got to take that off soon as i come off
the set stage anything yeah is it like
genuinely heavy
yeah it's crazy i wish i brought it i'll
let you wear it but i ain't breaking it
yeah i mean you have that on a lot i
didn't realize it like it was physically
heavy like it weighed down your neck no
it's a trophy girl it's a trophy now it
is it's a trophy
so
one thing um that is always apparent to
me when i'm around people who have
substantially more money than me is
there's lingo
that i've never heard of
like i remember so my favorite song by
the migos is time for me and in it you
go
there's five watches playing three flood
and i remember i said do you want us to
like what's wrong i said
i said
watch is playing in three floors i said
what is playing three flood i was just
talking about the number of watches i
got which is eight five
five playing and three flooded out okay
but so flood it out tell me what that
firewatch is playing three floor five
plane watches plain jane meaning no ice
and three flood i mean all three of them
is flooded out with i see this one is
flooded so okay so the flooded means it
has a bunch of diamonds it's flooded
it's flooded with diamonds it's flooded
with water it's flooded with ice you
know
at one point in your life didn't have a
bunch of money right you do have a bunch
of money and as you continue to grow
like definitions of things change right
so i'm sure when you were younger rich
meant one thing
but now rich probably means another
thing like what does being rich mean to
you now back in the day rich meant like
my first hundred thousand i felt like i
had a million dollars yeah and today um
rich's investments wealth you know what
i'm saying stocks and putting your money
up and saving and not buying so much ice
yeah i had to get that out of the way
first and then
get to it yeah so
no you're saying you're not buying ice
anymore that doesn't feel good that
doesn't feel true i like to reward
myself um i feel like jury is just
something that helps me feel good it
helped me thrive i like looking down at
my wrists saying that i came from
nothing or just looking down at my wrist
and seeing that
it's some diamonds or it could have been
handcuffs coming from the north you dig
i just like buying ice
for the money like what about the money
is success for you now like what does
that signify
i just want to keep getting it i just
want to keep getting money i want to
keep having fun i want to keep my craft
sharp i want to keep my music good
and um only sky's the limit so if i want
if i'm on millions i want to get
billions yeah you know so
i most definitely got to get a b before
i sit down i know it's you know
people kind of underestimate the
difference between a million and a
billion like they feel interchangeable
i mean but they're not interchangeable
yeah that's what that's what the strip
was going to say they'd be counting to
like yeah
one or two o'clock in the afternoon and
we come in there like ten thousand yeah
twenty thousand
are you a magic city guy a cheetah guy
honest guy we talking about a strip club
now i like i like a lure
really yeah cause i will say so
obviously we are both from gwinnett
county georgia yeah
the north yes north of atlanta so strip
clubs are not weird to us no it's not
it's not it's regular it's regularly
deadly but you gotta go in and make sure
you spend it show love you know what i'm
saying so when you saw lou williams
leaves the bubble
and at one point during his departure he
was at magic city
did you remember that i felt them
because i used to do crazy
[ __ ] all type of nights at like
just to get a plate of steak tips and
yellow rice you know what i'm saying
that food is crazy there yeah even the
lemon pepper wings but i like i like the
steak tips in the yellow rice that's my
favorite dish cause that's the thing
people thought he was lying when he said
no no i go to magic city to eat yeah the
food is crazy yeah strip club food is
some of the best food yeah
so i know he has the lemon pepper lou
wings there do you have anything on a
menu anywhere in atlanta oh yeah i do i
got these um
these cheese steaks i mean these philly
cheese steak rolls and like they they
normally come out big at big days you
know what i'm saying but when you get
them small they call them the honcho
minis so i like them i like my little my
little cheesesteak philly cheese that's
nice and small
like little cheesesteak nuggets
you gotta you gotta eat that busting
bean bunking
hitting i want to talk a little bit more
about you know athletes in this space
you know lou williams also raps have you
ever heard of his music yeah i heard
louis yeah for sure and one person who
is always posting ul's music online is
lebron james how does that happen like
how does lebron become
the guy that gets migos music first i
feel like he gets everyone's music first
but how does that happen i feel like
it's organic and then if we're just
feeling the vibe i know he need music
just to sometimes that unreleased music
cause he in the lab when nobody see it
he in the lab when
everybody thinking that he on vacation
so same way with music we got songs we
got records in our phone well you might
think we doing a show we got another hit
ready to go so you just got to get him
geared up like that on some exclusive
time mm-hmm cause you know the joke is
he always posted but everyone's like
okay is he a music guy does he give you
good feedback on your music most
definitely i think so for sure
he told me about that straightening and
when he got some straightening so like
i'm just like all right cool he know
that he know the objective you get the
point in it and i feel like
with music and sports i feel like we
need that fuel we you know saying is
both is both organically like married
you know i'm saying like we we were they
were a jury they dressed like us to hit
before they hit the court you know
saying we want to hoop like them you
know i'm saying we make basketball
rivers make bars and everything i feel
like
um
just daylight lifestyle now lifestyle go
together equally so i feel like just
music and them just go together so
taking their opinion really means
something yeah you know what i'm saying
so you send him straightening for sure
he says
don't not get strained of australia
that was the text that just said
that understand me i swear to god and
then you said
it's on yeah
and there was just an understanding of
of what that meant yeah okay i as
someone from the south heard that lyric
and knew exactly what you were trying to
say but people seem to be very confused
about
don't get nonsense straightened and then
when people ask you
you say
it means don't not get straight between
it and then they're like well what does
that mean so i want you to explain what
straighten it means without using the
words don't nothing gets straightened
and but straight okay so it's like
in basketball
say we lose a game
we got to play them
multiple times
um the next time you come you win
you got straightening it's like get back
it's it's kind of like
not trying to fail you know what i'm
saying always
straining out the problem before it
become a bigger issue
you know what i'm saying so
you want to straighten it before
bigger things happen you get what i'm
saying yeah you would try you're like i
can't can't say it like
but yes it's like you have to you want
to take care of it you know i'm saying
you want to handle it i know another
person obviously who loves your music is
trey young oh yeah my boy ice yeah but
you all have like i feel like that's one
of your best friends like you guys are
really close
obviously it's because he plays in
atlanta you guys met there but tell me
what it's like just
hanging out with trey
uh and he good man just cooling he'd
really just be chilling
he don't um like to do too much yeah
he's just recooling trying to work yeah
and i feel like i straight a gang has
just become like people now think like
that is literally about
him
oh yeah for sure
i straight again it's about my boy now
man just converted over to my dog he
he um he and the a he and the a to stay
and uh we proud of them and
it's just
it's just a good feeling when i see him
out there yeah i'm saying it's just
i don't know words can't even explain
it's just that's just my dog so whenever
you hoop i'll be feeling like i'm
hooping yeah that's it
now you and i both went to a bunch of
the hawks playoffs games we were very
excited our team made it to the eastern
conference finals finally yes and we
gonna do it again oh yeah i know when
the hawks played the sixers you bet some
money with was it meek or michael rubin
meek meet me you came back with michael
rubin yeah i mean he's just
that's a billionaire
so how much did you win
i won ten thousand no twenty thousand
twenty thousand
what's the most you've bet on any
sporting event
um
[Music]
let me see
oh fifty thousand with um drake georgia
gang georgia
was it georgia
oklahoma i think it was georgia oklahoma
rose bowl and then we came back
with georgia alabama
and i lost
we broke even okay yeah we broke even
but it was
that was a good one i also remember
hearing that i guess on tour you all
played i don't know it was 101 or like
five on five whatever but you won that
yeah we played five on five
the whole tour we were supposed to play
because because the the tour was set up
like an nba season i think it was like
80 dates or something like that so
every every in every spot we had like a
court but we started out playing the
game and it got so intense that we
didn't even play no more the whole the
whole tour
he got too intense we all had fun though
yeah that was that was the best tour
i've ever been on that was the most time
i fun fun time i had in my life like yes
it was
you can't even explain it like
basketball with my dogs 80 days
hitting the road playing the best music
we played we all got hits together we
kept coming out on his set
doing other songs and
doing all the songs we got it was just
organic it felt real good yeah and i
know you made one of the half court
shots oh yeah yeah and i drake was
supposed to pay you for it but last i
heard he had never paid did he end up
paying for not making it no no no i
ain't good i ain't get straight i think
we no he did give me 10 000. okay he did
give me ten thousand on that yes he did
he paid yeah you did an interview with
angie and i remember he was late he had
it he was like i was on them for a
minute so yeah i was on about my little
tent all right so i wanna talk about
your music obviously culture three huge
hit we were waiting a minute for it to
come out
how do you know when it's time to drop
an album
uh it was way over time for culture
three it was just like the pandemic
um we was trying to figure out what we
wanted to do and
um i think we we we had the album right
before it drop we was gonna come uh the
anniversary 2020 but then the pandemic
that's what kind of like threw
everything off didn't have to like
change the records because you know what
i'm saying like the timing was just was
just crazy because like just speaking
the lyrics and the lyrics that you
talking about was just
so different from what was going on and
all the like black lives matter things
start start coming up and it was just
like all right we got to change it we
got to get right we got to come back
we gotta drop the juice world record and
talk about you know what i'm saying real
life
problems with drugs we gotta we gotta
come back and drop a vaccine
and
and we had to like change it up and go
avalanche we had to put the old school
feel with the with the new school and
come in and do our do our [ __ ] on that
it was just like all right cool we got
to switch it up and drop this and let
the fans know we're here to stay
and then we had to like bring it back to
like day one
day one amigo north side [ __ ] you feel
what i'm saying i felt like we had to
put all that in one
and then we had a chip on our shoulder
so coaching three it was there's this
like challenge i guess of making your
album always feel like it's of the time
and that's kind of why you had to wait a
little bit for culture three to work is
that accurate right right
not not so much a time but just like
just things was going on it was just bad
right for like music i feel like music
wasn't even
connecting you know what i'm saying in
the last year so when i i put like a
tweet out i was like when when we drop i
feel like the world gonna start rotating
again like some are gonna start opening
again and i feel like that what it did
so when it's times like this i'm sure
you are inspired by the word by certain
things right things move you to write
they they inspire what you're talking
about in the music but is it harder or
easier
to be an artist right and write songs in
this past year and a half yeah it's
really tough because everything's
sensitive right now you know what i'm
saying so you don't want to you don't
want to almost speak your mind you want
to speak for the people too you know
what i'm saying so
it's just
um
we just got to find the right pocket for
it i think we haven't we haven't did
that yet but i think we gonna get uh
gonna get our moment we had them on we
we had a song called um crushing america
but we didn't we didn't put it out why
not
oh no we didn't oh no but it's it's it's
hard what's it about
that's crushing america what you know
you like you like explaining things
using the word of the thing you're
explaining once we once we say that it's
the picture that you already gotta paint
you paint you automatically just imagine
something but it's about like takeoff
came in and it was
going in about just like what's going on
in the world and i came in and sung like
some bars and said it came it's like
it's hard yeah i'll play it for you one
day when will it come out i don't know
there's certain rappers where you feel
like they coin certain things you know
people equate
t-pain and auto-tune like they say that
is his invention what do you feel like
is the thing that the migos invented
the triplet flow for show
yeah the triplet flow when nobody doing
it
before we came and right now everybody's
doing it and
it's a blessing yeah explain the triplet
flow just if people don't know exactly
flow the cadence the um
so yeah that's what everybody loved to
this day yeah and that's what you're
like people need to equate with the
migos specifically 2014 i was the most
influential rapper you know and
ever since then
sky's the limit for me yeah talk about
why like you feel like you were holding
that influence specifically at that time
um just just the flow was different the
swag was different um
just some young rich [ __ ] ready to go
i know david banner said i have the
quote i want to make sure i say it right
that he has seen people jack y'all style
jack the way you rap then go on tv and
act like they didn't rip you all off
do you agree with that
yeah
most definitely they just don't want to
give credit you don't want to you don't
want to come in saying you
you know what i'm saying being new and
saying you took somebody's style or
saying you got the style or don't want
to
say you influenced by too many
young people because you don't know how
people will take it so yeah it's all
good so but why do you think that is
because i know there has been different
times where you all have talked about
okay like we know this is ours you know
we began this now this person who maybe
at the time had a bigger platform is
doing it and people are believing that
it is their style like how do you
wrestle with kind of that frustration of
knowing that that's yours only person
that can really um really
pretty much argue about the flow like
who started it or who kind of like
pushed the influence is migos and drake
because he came in and got on versace
with us yeah um
so i feel like that was the first time
in the world i all heard the flow you
know what i'm saying when it was migos
and drake on the song so
and
even even with that like even before
that i feel like
nobody else wasn't using nobody else did
it nobody else use it so now when they
come out and say different people
influence and don't say the amigos i
don't understand how yeah cause even the
people they naming that influence them i
know for a fact we influenced them too
have rappers like come up to you and
talked about the influence you've had on
on their sound most definitely yeah most
definitely
when has that happened
you just got to keep that to you know to
myself and yeah you know so i don't want
to just credit no artists but
they know i'm the real they know i'm the
realest [ __ ] alive
so when we think about let's call it the
starting five of atlanta rappers
okay but you all are one like i'm
counting migos as one of those
what's that starting five for you when
it comes to atlanta rap
atlanta rap mm-hmm
um
my starting five in atlanta
gotta be migos
gucci
um
two chainz
we got one more
yeah what amigos gucci two chains two
more
okay uh
it's tough there's so many i mean
because you also have yeah
you have andre 3k
or outcast if you want to count that
future outcast
that's five s5
one thing i really like about artists is
you feel like you know kind of what
place they were at in life when certain
albums came out
who do you think you were for the first
culture
versus who you were for culture three
um i was just young you know saying not
just ready to work everywhere not paying
attention to like
just like the business side of music but
like on
on and just like life you know what i'm
saying so
that
that's it yeah i ain't given i ain't
care about nothing
i was just going crazy
i undercut about five times already well
yeah
but like i was just i was just going
crazy on culture one i was just like
gas on the gas just ready to go
now i'm just like real
mental about my moves and really think
about it you know what i'm saying
that's it is there anything like what
were the advantages of you know kind of
that free-flowing style and attitude
that you have for culture you never know
what you get like you don't give a [ __ ]
it's just like damn i ain't even know
they was liking that i was just having
fun yeah like even with versace we was
having fun we were having so much fun
and laughing and just like
joking about the song just being too
many versace was just saying too many
factors i was like oh my god
but it's like hell not record that [ __ ]
right now so we recorded it and it was
up it was over with it someone said to
me once that
making it to the top
is not the same as making it at the top
what does what you mean so
like going to the top right that journey
to the top is different than being at
the top and staying there
do you agree that that's true nah okay
tell me why not for me i just feel like
once i'm at the top i still get i got to
stay there and i i do the same thing i
do the same thing going to the top and i
do the same thing at the top i don't
never stop doing
like i always record five six songs a
day like after i leave here i'm finna go
record mm-hmm like five six mo songs i
shoot videos on the go it's just like
remaining just consistent just stand
like like brian like braun said like his
his older self he he know what he'll do
to his younger self because he already
you know what i'm saying he putting he
put them together he put it together
mentally and still with that give no
[ __ ] mentality but
you just know where to put it yeah
what's something you haven't
accomplished musically that you want to
accomplish
um i most definitely want to
win everything that all the musicians
before me won like grammys and
you know just vmas i feel like we need
some of that and that's it and just keep
making good music more platinum records
more number ones
so i know you produce as well and i was
talking to my friend gabe who is
somewhere he's right there um before
this interview just things that he'd
want to know from about you
and he was like okay see these gabe
questions yeah yeah this one is gabe's
question i liked it i was like i'm gonna
ask
yeah
he said okay so if we gave migo or if we
gave quavo and the migos this like
old-school type beat
and he can put
three people on it what beat would you
choose like it's a sample what beat
would you pick and who would the
features be
school
no i think new school people
old school people too yes okay uh mo
definitely be a james brown beat
um
any one of those beats because he most
definitely had the hip-hop sound
um
and who would i get on it uh
i did so many songs with so many people
uh i get jay-z on it
i get jay-z kanye
and uh
kanye and drake
jay-z kanye and drake all on one song
i'm sure that would be a interesting
song yep for a variety of ways but i
mean i think if three of those people
are on a song i don't really think you
it could go wrong the final product
wouldn't go wrong i don't know about the
creation of the song but the final
the final product though it'll take a
long time to come out but we can't lose
it'll take a long time to come out for
sure but uh what's it sound like what's
it sound like i'm not asking you to rap
this time but it's giving me what what
that song sounds like because i think
it's really interesting that you produce
but i don't feel like you talk about the
fact that you produce a lot i don't know
what it sounds i'm just if i'm just the
producer i just wanna i'm gonna just
cook the beat and i just want you to
just lay this track i just want you to
just go in you gotta come to the studio
so you don't know a lot about me you
gotta yeah i don't know about the studio
i'm a sports i'm a sportsman music you
just say the words you gotta come in and
watch still have you ever been to like
um
benny hunna yes of course yeah i'm
saying the bocce bus you did what i'm
saying they cook it in front of you
so we cook it in front of you you know
i'm saying you can watch it
you can watch me cooking in front of you
okay we got your chicken your steak
your fried rice extra egg no vegetables
okay
stir-fry
got to cook it like a stir-fry
you know dj the real gonna make the beat
yeah oh my god that's the season what is
okay so you talk about the studio tell
me the experience of being in the studio
at cueva i've heard a bunch of things of
what it's like to be in the studio with
dj khaled i hear it is just luxurious he
does whatever and and it's just a great
time
with cueva no my studio session is
not like that at all okay
i wouldn't come no more no i'm scared
it's not like
it's just some good vibes all of us in
there
it's very cloudy you know um okay
the room is very cloudy do you write
better high
i just said the room is cloudy i write
better do you write better when it's
cloudy i write better in the sky
yeah okay i write better in the sky and
um
and um i just make sure like i just make
sure that
somebody got some crazy beats and then
i'm just ready to go like when you see
me you'll be like damn that [ __ ] crazy
because you really make a song in 25
minutes yeah make a song in like 25
minutes i only got to do the first hook
in the verse you know the rest of the
boys come in and go crazy yeah and vice
versa they do the same
uh you were a quarterback in high school
shout out to bergamar yep shout out to
my gang how how good were you
how was i
i elaborated i did a couple i had broke
a couple records i still hold him a
little bit um
i had fun
and left-handed i was good mm-hmm
that was it
if you if that was a thing that you
picked right you're like what i want to
do is plan the nfl or play in the nba
whichever sport you feel like is your
best
is that something you feel like you
could have accomplished was your talent
there
yeah my talent was there my my mind
wasn't
well my talent was there for sure i
couldn't i could have did it if i wanted
to but that's the only dream that i i
feel like i didn't
i didn't my goal you know so i didn't
feel like i didn't get and i think
that's everybody's but
i really i i mastered everything i
wanted to do and i just didn't do that
that's it
it's so it's so interesting though
because i feel like
a lot of rappers are like i wish i'm not
saying you wish but they say like i wish
like that was the thing i could do it's
like be in the nba be in the nfl like
what is and yours is different because
you actually played and you were good at
those respective sports
but like what is it about those leagues
that you dislike this would have been so
funny i just i don't think it's i don't
think people feel like they wish i just
feel like people just think they like
could have just went a little bit harder
when they was a kid know what i'm saying
and you remember them talks when they
used to be like you're in 12th grade
you're going you're going you're going
to remember this you're going to want to
be back in high school again and
everybody just take that for granted but
um just that i just feel like
if you just had this same mentality
thinking when you got older you'll be
all right but
i don't want to be in the league yeah
okay
i think being a rapper i actually have
had this conversation like a week ago
i think being a rapper of all of the
famous occupations would be the best and
the most fun because i don't think
rappers
like robbers can really do whatever they
want
you know what i mean like there's not
like an athlete there's some stuff like
you cannot do yeah for sure you just
have
the world is yours do you feel that way
like you have like you're not as
restricted as really any other
profession everybody got
responsibilities yeah you got to be
responsible but um
i do what i want to do yeah because
that's the
foundation i built yeah but um
some people can't do what they want to
do some rappers can't yeah i do what i
want to do though
and also the crazier things you do i
feel like the better the songs are
because you're like rapping about things
that have actually
occurred at some point yeah
yeah yeah it's crazy so as we kind of
you know wrap this up one of the reasons
i was really excited to have you on and
you have been outstanding um is
i don't really know how many times you
have been able to just like talk freely
about yourself and your music i've never
really seen you do like a
long form sit down
and i know that when people are
rappers right there's cueva but there
also is like quavious and i'm sure they
intersect in a bunch of different ways
but what are some things that you feel
like
have become like your persona that we
always see
that aren't who you are in private
i don't know there's no you're just
always quavo
there's that's not true
oh no
i don't know are you as
maybe as boisterous as we would all
think are you always
happy and having fun like what is what
are you like at home
i got energy
always bring the energy always yeah good
great energy yeah that's all i'm here
for so nothing ever brings you down
nope
well that is a very nice way to live
things bring me down
i'ma hit you up next time something
brings me down and maybe you'll give me
some energy stuff bring you down get off
the ground
i'm gonna have a nice little assign line
for you you're gonna be like when i get
down i'm gonna get out yeah i ain't got
time to be
messing around yeah i've never had like
a
i've never had a um and i'm not you
when i'm feeling down don't look down
you don't got time to be messing around
keep going don't be a clown
look around
okay take your surrounds yes
no and i'm not i am not saying i want
this because it's kind of like a
nightmare of mine i've never had like a
name drop no not that i've never had
like a name drop in anything i hadn't
named up in a movie once but never a rap
song and i'm like i just feel like
that's gonna be great
oh god okay i got you i got you i got
you okay but no this is amazing
thank you for your time also quavo the
actor i'm excited to see that movie
whenever oh yeah never seen talk about
none of the action yeah you want to plug
it tell me about you tell me about the
acting nero
malkovich you know what i'm saying
um
it's a movie called watch me in the
river
and um i'm excited it's one of my first
you know what i'm saying movies like an
action drummer yeah it's gonna take you
through a roller coaster you're gonna be
sad you're gonna be crying
then you're gonna
see me yeah
is this like is it a pretty big big role
yes it's a big role my boy coyote i'm
coyote
how hard is it memorize the lines or did
it come easy to you
uh i was there for like a month i think
they were shooting we was shooting in
puerto rico
and um
i just made sure i was just
trying to like
be organic as possible because they
wouldn't tell you when you kind of like
mess up and i thought that was like
a bad thing yeah so i was like they're
not telling me what i was doing they're
not telling me it's like they mean
you're doing something good because if
if you messing up they'll get they'll do
a thousand takes until they get it right
so i was just go in and just like go in
like twice or three times and then just
be done for the day
and then they were telling me i was
killing it
that's great so so when i see the movie
i'ma hopefully kill it yeah so i don't
know how this works well you get to see
at least some type of cut of it before
yeah okay yeah i seen cuts i seen cuz
did you love it i got chills
oh my god good job i did a good job
wait okay so do we know when does this
come out
uh i don't know when to date i don't
want to be wrong so yeah yeah but i mean
like you worked with robert de niro on a
movie that's like pretty
no that's huge that's huge i had to tell
my mama that one yeah what'd she say
she went crazy damn why not she went
crazy do you like hit anyone up for
acting tips or you were just like i'm
gonna go in there and do this and see
what they tell me now i just pay
attention to like rob dinero i paid
attention to
um jack houston i was just watching them
and watch how serious they get right
before the camera you know i'm saying
right before they say action how they
like just try to channel something and
uh and i was just kind of putting that
together and just trying to just
calm down and get you know what i'm
saying get to get the butterflies out
and just watch people in front of me i'm
i'm pretty good with that yeah oh my
gosh okay i'm gonna i'm gonna be
watching
so actor
rapper
producer is there a fourth thing we have
to add to this uh in five years no you
gotta add my athletic
oh yes i'm an athlete but i'm just not
an elite athlete so is there a feeling
you gotta be in the lead to be an
athlete right totally agree okay cool is
there a fifth thing we're gonna add to
this in five years fifth thing
in five years yep [ __ ] billionaire
billionaire we're speaking it yeah you
gotta add that gotta add that b for sure
no thank you this was so much fun thanks
for coming thank you
[Music]